jusqu'ici officier de l'armée malienne
il est désormais le nouveau chef
autoproclamé du mali le colonel assimi
goïta patron des forces spéciales
malienne est à l'origine du putsch
militaire qui a renversé le président
malien ibrahim boubacar keïta
depuis le ministère de la défense
vingt-quatre heures après la dernière
allocution de l'ex président il s'est
présenté à la nation il était de mon
devoir c'est de les assurer de son
rapport à la qualité du service la fin
de l'état cette envie de piloter ici
d'abord pour laquelle nous avons assuré
notre soutien et l'aide du de commencer
à travailler
des propos qui nous rassurer ni l'union
européenne ni la communauté
internationale qui ont fermement
condamné ce coup d'état le conseil paix
et sécurité de l'union africaine suspens
le mali de l'union africaine jusqu'au
retour de l'ordre constitutionnel et
demande la libération du président
boubacar kéita du premier ministre et
des autres responsables du gouvernement
arrêtés par la force par l'armée
la lutte contre les groupes terroristes
et la défense de la démocratie et de
l'état de droit sont indissociables en
sortir c'est provoquer l'instabilité et
affaiblir notre combat ce n'est pas
acceptable pour l'opposition réunie au
sein du mouvement du 5 juin
ce coup d'état a au contraire permis le
départ du président ibrahim boubacar
keïta et de son gouvernement qu'elle
réclamait depuis des mois mais la
population malienne reste elle partagée
c'est bien cela qui a fait couler tant
c'est le peuple malien qui a fait
circuler quand le peuple a crié qui on a
demandé à l'ex-chef d'état yves le baut
arteta d'écouter son peuple il n'a pas
voulu dont l'armée c'est assumé et puis
c'est tout moi je vois pas le problème
je condamne le coup d'état parce que ça
n'avance pas un pays ça nous met
toujours arrêter les mairies terre et
qui y viennent nous promet beaucoup de
choses mais rien ne s'est passé
réellement dans les normes
c'est bien la question qui agite le pays
le colonel simi goïta et ses hommes qui
se sont imposés par les armes
vont-ils pacifiquement quitter le
pouvoir